افاد مراسل الجزيره في سوريا بان الاف
النازحين بمخيمات ريفي حلب وادلب شمالها
غربي البلاد يعانون اوضاعا صعبه جراء
المنخفض الجوي الذي يضرب المنطقه من جهه
قال الدفاع المدني في مناطق المعارضه ان
اوضاع النازحين في المخيمات ماساويه مع
هطول الثلوج والامطار وانخفاض درجه
الحراره وانعدام مواد ووسائل التدفئه
معنى الان من احد مخيمات النازحين في ريف
حلب مراسله جزيره محمد الجزائري ومن احد
مخيمات النازحين بريف ادلب مراسل الجزيره
ادهم ابو الحسام ارحب بكم ابو الحسام ازمه
تتكرر سنويا واللاجئ وحده يواجه هذه
الماسه كيف تبدو الصوره
نعم في الحقيقه ازدهار هذا المنخفض الجوي
الذي ربما يطول بحسب توقعات الارصاد
الجويه لثلاث ايام المقبله زاد من معاناه
الاف العائلات النازحه هنا شمال غرب سوريا
خصوصا في المخيمات العشوائيه هذه المخيمات
التي تفتقر الى شبكات الصرف الصحي الى
الطرقات المرصوفه المعبده وايضا
نلاحظ ان تساقط الامطار خلال الساعات
الماضيه بكميات كبيره الداله الانتشار
الوحل والطين في ازقه المخيمات
كما ان العائلات غالبيتها تشكو من ضعف
استجابه المنظمات الانسانيه خلال الايام
الماضيه العائلات تحاول تامين الدفع
لاطفالها عبر ما تجمعه من اغصان الزيتون
ومن الاخشاب على اطراف الطرقات اضافه الى
مواد من البلاستيك والنايلون من مكبات
النفايات القريبه من المخيمات غالبا يتم
حرق هذه المواد
مدافئ بدائيه هذه المدافئ تسببت بامراض
كثيره خصوصا للاطفال الرضع نتحدث عن رابط
تنفسيه امراض جلديه اضافه الى ازدياد
معاناه ايضا كبار السن من حيث التنقل
والحركه وايضا مع انخفاض درجات الحراره
ايضا يعانون من امراض في المفاصل بحسب ما
روى لنا احد الشيوخ هنا في هذا المخيم فان
البرد زاد من معاناته فهو لا يستطيع
الخروج من الخيمه ولا ايضا يستطيع التحرك
من تحت حقيقه الاغطيه فهم يعتمدون على
الاغطيه بشكل كبير لتامين الدفع
لاجسادهم
لاحظنا ايضا في بعض المخيمات القريبه من
هنا حركه لمنظمات محليه تحاول توزيع ما
توفر لها من منظمات داعمه سواء من الحطب
او من فحم البيرين ولكن بحسب مدراء
المخيمات فان هذه المواد التي يتم توزيعها
فهي لا في جزء يسير مما يحتاجه الاهالي في
المخيمات ربما لتجاوز هذه المحنه وتجاوز
هذا البرد الذي ربما يطول لي ثلاث ايام
مقبله نحن نتحدث عن حراره ما دون السفر
وربما ايضا تنخفض مع ساعات الليله نعم
ننتقل اليك محمد الجائز الجزائر يعني ما
يمكن ان يضاف لما ذكره ادهم قبل قليل
نعم ازدهار في الحقيقه حال مخيمات ريف حلب
لا يختلف كثيرا عن مخيمات
ريف ادلب ولكن هنا في مرتفعات منطقه عفرين
الثلوج غطت المخيمات وباتت الصعوبه
والمعاناه اكبر مع انخفاض درجات الحراره
بشكل اكبر
وبعض وتهدم بعض الخيام الاهالي هنا في هذا
المخيم وكما نشاهد ايضا بعدسه الكاميرا
يعتمدون على الخيام والتي مزقتها الرياح
ومزقتها الامطار والثلوج خلال السنوات
الماضيه ومع كل عام يقومون باعاده ترميمها
باغطيه بلاستيكيه او اغطيه قماشيه لصد
الرياح والبرد ولكن الامطار تتسلل الى
خيامهم مع كل
منخفض جوي وان الخيام ايضا بات ثقل كبير
عليها الثلوج فيضطرون الى السهر طوال
ساعات الليل
لازاله الثلوج عن هذه الخيام
وازاله والبقاء
ساعات الليل يقظين
لخوفا من
تهدم هذه الخيام فوق الاطفال وخوفه وفوق
العائلات ايضا يشتكون قله المساعدات التي
تقدم لهذه المخيمات هذه المخيمات
العشوائيه التي يقطنها عدد كبير وبحسب
فريق منسق والاستجابه النقاطنيه ام
المخيمات العشوائيه تخطى ال 400 الف نازح
هذا رقم كبير حقيقه في هذه المخيمات التي
هي مبنيه بين اشجار الزيتون وعلى اطراف
المدن وتفتقر للخدمات من صرف صحي او شبكات
مياه او حتى كهرباء او ما شابه المعاناه
كبيره جدا ودرجات الحراره منخفضه جدا
والتخوف من التساقط من السقوط من الثلوج
خلال الايام القادمه كبير لدى الاهالي
والمعاناه هذه تتكرر مع كل عام ويشتكي
منها الاهالي ومن قله الدعم من قبل المن
ويجدون ان الحل الوحيد لماساتهم هو عوده
كريمه او عوده امنه الى مدنهم وقراهم شكرا
جزيلا لك من احد مخيمات النازحين في ريف
حلب مراسل الجزيره محمد الجزائري شكرا
ايضا لمراسل الجزيره ادهم ابو الحسام كان
معنا من احد مخيمات النازحين بريف ادلب